alright so now we're going to have our
closing session a reflective discussion
which is going to be led by Beth bit
lack she is director of the Burke
library at union theological seminaries
which is a part of columbia university
libraries she joined columbia and in
2013 after serving as collection
assessment and analysis librarian at
dartmouth college library she in
addition to her MLS she has a PhD in
religious and theological studies in a
master's in theological studies and
she's a member of the board and current
president of American theological
Library Association and at this time I'd
like to ask not only Beth to come up but
any of the remaining speakers our
panelists if you could come up as well
and be a part of the discussion thanks
so I'm going to go back to something Bob
said this morning about what was that
crackpot ideas but I like the baking
metaphor that we got started here so
these are half-baked ideas that sounds
better with a little bit of special
sauce in there so I was reflecting on
what I was going to talk about for a few
minutes before we have an open
discussion and during the lunch time
someone said I look forward to hearing
you preach this afternoon I'm not
ordained and someone else said no I
think it's that Beth's going to pastor
us to through the conversation so I
guess I was selected because of my
background so it's a good thing i'm
going to talk about how I think my
background has formed me into the leader
that I think I have become an and
becoming so my background in theological
studies I think has helped me in a
number of ways and I started writing a
few ways out on piece of paper and I
stopped at seven as seven is a good
number to stop at it's a number of
completion so stop at seven so first my
training is specifically in biblical
studies so as a small child I was quite
amazed at leaders as depicted
in the biblical literature and what
struck me was that these people had
major character flaws right I could
relate to them yeah there are crazy
folks and I spent many years writing on
one crazy man Ezekiel and that should
say at all if you know anything about
the Book of Ezekiel it's just darn crazy
I felt right at home so even as a small
child I was impacted by theological
studies and seeing models put forward so
even the imperfect human condition can
provide leadership then when I got to
seminary I had to take these practical
theology classes but i'll tell you the
concept of emotional intelligence I use
that everyday in my work so
understanding my emotional level
understanding the emotional levels of
others and how to move people to an
emotional level that can then be open to
change it's a very important lesson also
communication skills something we worked
on all the time in seminary and
something I value every day in my life
as a director and also as a board
president we do something else in
seminary this weird thing called
reflective practice it sounds more
complicated than it really is you
constantly reflect on your actions in
your behaviors and their impact so this
is part of my problem this comes very
naturally to me as some of you might
know I like to reflect so when I do
something I think about when I what's
that all about what motivated me so this
aspect of reflective practice i think
has informed my leadership i have a high
level of self-awareness thanks to some
ordination requirements such as heavy
duty psychological testing
and the constant discipline to be
self-aware and I think that is an
important aspect of leadership I'm
constantly reframing things or trying to
look at situations from different
perspectives and I think this is another
representation of a level of
self-awareness that one can have if one
has been through seminary we would hope
they would have it integrative seminars
were an important part of my theological
education it's where you take theory all
that stuff that you read about and how
does it relate to the real world so
theory and praxis is what makes up an
integrative seminar and I kind of think
every day is an integrative seminar for
me and then there's those loaded
theological terms that I've tried to
reinterpret for myself so things like
hope grace exile Providence evangelize
these are all loaded theological terms
but they have meaning i think in our
library context so if you can't talk
about what your library does and does
well or evangelize then you better go to
seminary you need to understand what
grace can mean sometimes out of nowhere
something wonderful can happen and you
just seize the day and move along and
say thank you very much and don't
question it there are I've had a new
understanding of the term exile I won't
say anything more at this point
I've worked in a variety of contexts in
a variety riety of geographical
locations I'll say nothing more I think
someone from a former institution is
here living in exile in the wilderness
Jane you can ask a question later and
finally I would say my training in
research methods has been essential for
my work I was trained heavily in source
critical and historical critical methods
and that means defining and solving
problems that sound relevant to
leadership identifying and evaluating
evidence using evidence to articulate
arguments and to make decisions all part
of what I was trained as a biblical
scholar so I take my little seminary
toolkit and I hit the road and I found
myself in situations where leadership
opportunities are just there and I seize
the day and fill the gap so as a TLA
president I'm leading the atl a board in
a strategic thinking process and I think
Elliott is gone but he and I should talk
more about this so we at our last board
meeting formulated a big hairy audacious
goal or a bee hag a big hairy audacious
goal and in June we're going to continue
talking about that goal and writing out
a vivid description or what does an
envision future look like if we were to
obtain that goal in my role on the board
I've also been thinking about how to
move from individual leadership to
collective leadership so our board
process is such that we deliberate and
we try to come to one voice we have 12
people and we're 12 or more are gathered
there are at least 13 opinions in the
room but we agree to disagree and then
we support whatever decision is made
beyond the boardroom so we never give
the impression that
we are a divided board and finally as a
board member I've been very concerned
about how to identify and engage future
leaders so I've been doing a lot of
research on voluntary associations and
associations are made up of members and
probably sixty to eighty percent of
those members just want to belong to
something the same study sites that
perhaps fifteen to twenty percent of
that group may want to do something but
it's a very small percent this
particular study sites two to five
percent that want to be leaders so the
majority of people in a group just want
to belong to that group so how do you
identify that two to five percent and
then how do you nurture them so that's
just some of my own personal reflections
and just to show that I have done my
integrative seminar and have been
reflecting properly throughout the day
this morning Bob provided a very helpful
overview talked about leadership
mentorship mastery and mystery and I was
quite taken as a theologian or want to
be theologian on the importance of the
mystery in his conversation the
importance of realizing that you're not
always sure where you're going or where
you're going to end up but that having a
strong community you can face that
mystery together and Elliott introduced
us to the concepts of competency trap
and disagreement deficit and again that
competency trap that he was talking
about led me back to those crazy
prophets and staff and challenging the
status quo this is something that comes
easier to some than others so how to be
a model of speaking truth to power is a
common way it's expressed in seminary
life in the seminary that I work at
does this very well sometimes to its own
detriment and the disagreement deficit
you know how can I take the skills that
I've learned in pastoral care and
counseling class and in a hospital
chaplaincy setting to challenge people
in caring ways smiling as Elliot said
but also I feel like it's a
responsibility to disagree at times and
to put forward other points of view
after that we had a wonderful
presentation that outlined a successful
implementation of a multi-faceted
professional development program and
this will challenge us to think about
ourselves individually and collectively
I especially liked the pipeline
discussion because I was a master
cataloger once upon a time and I could
catalog really well but then I had to
start supervising people and cataloging
and supervision are not the same right
and then you have to direct something
cataloging supervision and direction you
know being a director are not the same
thing so I can easily understand that
pipeline metaphor and then we had four
panelists who embodied leadership thank
you very much Karen whether or not they
admitted it I certainly saw them
embodying leadership and they talked
about their organizations and again
raised this question of when does
individual leadership morph into
collective leadership and Courtney thank
you very much for challenging us to
provide leadership opportunities and
also for emphasizing the need to create
and nurture and retain a diverse
workforce
I also am very touched by what you say
about the everyday leadership that
librarians provide and I'm sure if we
took a few minutes to reflect quietly
and share is a large than share back to
the large group we could all think of a
few examples I challenge you just to
think of three mental notes to yourself
I'm sure you can think of three ways in
which you have been a leader so those
are just a few of my thoughts as the day
has gone on and it's been a great day so
I invite you to talk with us a little
more get up stretch two microphones and
share with us your takeaways from the
day what ideas and concepts will you
implement in your own context what are
you going to discuss with your
colleagues supervisors and supervisees
anyone who wasn't able to come here what
are you going to take back so I invite
your thoughts and most of the group is
still here so we're going to have a
great conversation and you'll be walking
to the microphones and you'll be sharing
your thoughts with us and you'll be
smiling when you disagree great so we've
got someone over here on the right hi my
name is Paul Glassman and from felician
college in Bergen County I very
intrigued by the idea of the bee hag and
I had that my question centers on that
um have you ever committed to the big
idea and i love that connection it makes
me think of Daniel Daniel Burnham's
overused phrase make no little plans
have you ever made big plans and
committed to the big idea and then
realized had a certain point that you
can't achieve it and if so what do you
do at that point do we have people here
who would like to share that experience
I have a I have a big plant but it
hasn't it hasn't I have a big plant that
I didn't talk about because it's not at
a time to be spoken up so I don't know
yet if it's going to fail or not but I'm
hoping it won't I can whoops is this off
yeah you know I can think of a number of
now I've been a librarian for about 20
years now so I've been around long
enough to have launched many things that
I've then had to kill at the end because
you know we have a life cycle for our
projects and life cycle for our tools
and our services and there is a time for
them and then there's a time to say
goodbye and I you know I have it with
great remorse that I have to I mean
sadness but I feel like that is part of
my job I mean I it's like I've planned a
lot of flowers and then some i have to
take out some time and and and so dear
things like i'm picturing one dear thing
that really put my heart and soul into
that you know had my fingerprints all
over it and then i left that area and we
be buried it even though it was
tremendously popular and it was just
weird we have to make such difficult
decisions now about where we put our
resources in our time and I and I call
it killing puppies
because we have a lot of puppy I think
the past or better step in right now
should I just out there you probably
know what I mean but but don't you think
that part of being a leader is
recognizing when it is time to pull the
plug on something I think that it's it's
altogether too prevalent that people
just you know they've committed to
something and they feel like they have
to just keep on committing to it long
after everybody understands that it's
not working anymore so really it's it's
it's it's an impressive thing to be able
to kill that puppy when when that puppy
is needs to be put down well thank you I
will not call the ASPCA
I think I better add a couple words
there we don't want to end on that
metaphor so again I'm thinking back to
what Bob said this morning about the
importance of the mystery component and
that you really don't always know where
you're going in that that that thing may
change and involve and I would also say
for me what's often the most important
is the process not the product so it's
not that we got to what we we said we
were gonna you know where we said we're
going to go or we produced what we said
we were going to produce but it's that
growth and development that happened
along the way how's that is that better
than the other see this theological
education pays off every day over here
on the left so we'll take it in a whole
other direction now after the the death
of small pets I'm an Langley from
Princeton University and I really like
this is probably more of a comment or
maybe something for people to think
about but I really like the the theme
that has kind of been overarching over
the whole day that hasn't necessarily
been explicitly spoken about but it was
it's about becoming a leader but then
how leaders inspire new leaders and i
think the word that was missing that I
kept wanting to hear people talk about
was the need to trust people to be in
charge of their own leadership and you
can lead people but then at some point
you have to step away and trust that
they're going to go off and and become a
butterfly and so there's that trust
issue that I think is really important
part of the process so thank you so much
the yep I mean that's the other thing
that I was thinking about in terms of a
question that I didn't ask but i think
is equally important is how are you
receptive to leadership or how are you
receptive to mentorship and so i think
just as much as we've talked about what
does it take to be a leader in what is
good practice in leading it's just as
important to sort of understand how to
follow and how to be mentored and so i
think that could probably be another
full day of conversations but as people
take away from this and think about it
that piece of it
should be a part of the takeaway I think
there was something that mean that
Elliot mentioned earlier about you know
these not being Lyford that's you know
decisions that are being made which you
know I jot it down well then if every
decision isn't a life or death you know
situation then you know having more
opportunities for leadership you know
could be wrote low risk and high reward
so there is that that trust element that
you know what's what's the worst that
someone could really screw something up
and let's trust that they're gonna do
the right thing because I'm putting them
in the situation to do the right thing
and hey every everyone lives and it's
the puppies live we're okay it's a
really good point i just also want to
just I just have to add to that because
as somebody who's done a lot of leading
to um sometimes I think the focus needs
to be on the person not the thing and we
put the focus often too much on the
thing so when I give an assignment to
somebody and I know it's a stretch
assignment it's for them it's not so
much for the outcome or the product that
they're going to create it's it's to
help them along their developmental path
there to help coach them it's an
opportunity for growth so again back to
that growth mindset if you see
everything as opportunity for growth
then you're more folk it's a it's a it's
I think it's more productive to focus on
the growth than it is necessarily on the
tool the outcome the thing the product
that they're creating and for anyone
who's been building a bibliography
during this event in my board work
there's a book that's been influential
called the will to govern well and it
hasn't its subtitle trust knowledge and
nimbleness I think and trust as a board
has become very important and trust
between the board and the chief
executive officer is very important as
well on the right can you hear me first
I'd like to say that the Columbia
University Libraries does not endorse
killing of any pets
no mammals no I would like actually your
comments on because what I've seen is
sometimes for people especially that are
new to organizations or new to their
career being less bold and they should
be about confronting libraries or
library library leadership or even
people you know that are out there that
they could be learning from to actually
be pretty forward and asking for
assistance to mentorship or having real
conversations about that and i would i'd
like wondering if you could reflect on
that about your experience at it and
maybe let us know how you don't have you
been bowled in that and actually asking
something from the from your
organization or the people that you see
in your organization's that could be of
assistance i just did an exercise where
I asked 25 people what they thought my
three best qualities were and it was
part of a development thing I'm doing
and I was really surprised by the
responses and one of the things that was
pretty consistent was some comment that
had to do with my persistence my
perseverance and I think that is a
quality that has served me so well there
was somebody who talked about you know
the 30 year project that she started to
nurture that didn't come to fruition
that's my life that is like my career
right there I mean I have to have the
long view because it takes us a long
time and things aren't always it right
at the right time you know so much of
what I try to do is just about timing
and then it's also about revealing the
reason communicating the reason over and
over again so I mean this is kind of
taking off topic but i have to say that
the the best tool i have in my tool kit
is is an arsenal of needs assessment
tools so focus groups surveys
discussions all of those things are just
ripe to help me create a case for doing
something new so i would have loved to i
didn't have a chance to talk about how
all this library leadership had this all
devel
you know what were the seeds that I
planted or that other people planted
that was able to create such a robust
program I but it and I didn't talk about
it because it's so different you know
everybody has different seeds I think
the gift that you have to hit that's
good to have is the ability to see
that's a seat oh that's the sea oh look
at that and then you create a story that
sounds very compelling that builds a
story for why should I I mean I've had
five jobs at the Minnesota and each one
I've invented and talk people into
funding me for you know I would love to
teach people how to do that I don't know
you know this again often we all have
strengths that we don't even know you
know it's like no big deal because it's
just easy to you and you all have those
well that's just that's just one of my
is the kind of thing where it's like
that I wish I could just put it together
a training program for that maybe
someday I'll figure that out but I think
that's exactly the quality that we need
in libraries and I've completely gone
off track from what you said him but do
you want to follow up with that or you
want me to company you me both babe
anything else want to come you know I I
do I actually this is an interesting
question to me because if a few years
ago I applied to go to the Harvard
leadership program and I have no desire
to be a director or a UL or a president
or a no desire to go beyond maybe even
the second step of that pipeline but I
felt that that there was an important
role for you know the soldiers in the
organization to also understand how
leadership can benefit the entire
organism that they're part of and it
didn't work out and I think that it's it
didn't work out that I that I was able
to go I mean not that it didn't work out
that I went but I feel like there is an
emphasis on sending folks to these big
leadership or training programs only if
they are on that I
track and I think there is a place for
folks who want to lead from behind to a
certain extent to have that same sort of
leadership training yeah looks kind of
inspired by the to thinking about out
for me leadership it's going to be a
while before I'm going to be practically
in a position to want to be in a more
supervisory role the ba achieve
librarian someday or I do have
aspirations to do that at some point but
right now there's a lot of things I want
to do a brute long before I start doing
that but there's a lot of leadership to
be done in committees and projects and I
think that's where like the leadership
always gets completed with like being a
supervisor and being in charge of people
but it really is about as much inspiring
people and leading a group of people
together whether you're really
officially in charge or like where I am
where it's very flat but you you can
rally the troops to work on a project
and get everyone to buy in and come to
some consensus on some ideas so I think
that's where it's especially libraries
where there are a lot of people that
don't have aspirations to move up or
there just aren't those opportunities to
find ways to develop that kind of
leadership among the the lower level
staff is really helpful and we have a
question on the left I Dom Nielsen at
metro i just wanted to offer that when
I'm not wearing my metro hat I'm the
Past Chair of those solo division at SLA
and I put together a webinar series for
them that we just had our first webinar
it was every day leadership for special
and solo librarians and Pat Wagner bled
that webinar and she gave everybody at
the end of three assignments to do and
they were find a mentor asked for
feedback from someone you respect and
ask a politically savvy person what you
should be doing differently
and I just wanted to ask about the
second one about talking to someone
about things that you do that may you
may find critical of yourself so
trusting somebody that you know to say
to you what do you think I should be
doing differently or behaving
differently or acting differently that I
may not be aware of that's kind of one
of the things that I think is part of
leadership and I'd be interested to hear
what you have to say I think there's a
step that has to happen before that and
that is to set down some ground rules
about how that feedback is given and how
it's going to be received so I'm
teaching a class right now called
writing for chemists and the way that
we've set up the class is it's a
workshop and so we spend about 45
minutes each class workshopping a piece
of writing 5 to 10 pages that one of the
students is written and we spent a good
45 minutes or an hour in one of the
early classes laying down what the
ground rules were that everybody could
agree upon that we could then you know
document that have that as sort of a
recourse as people are giving feedback
to remind them about best practices and
I was saying this to somebody during
lunch for me that comes from an art
background where in that case we're
talking about the writing we're not
talking about the person and so what you
bring up is a really interesting
question that when you are talking about
the person how does that change but I
think there's a lot that can be done
with language there's a lot that can be
done about my perception of something as
opposed to saying you are doing it this
way where you actually end up making it
about yourself or it's about the person
who's giving feedback it's not about as
much about the person who's getting the
feedback and so I think if you can set
down some ground rules and I'm sure
there's literature out that out there
about how to do this and Beth can
probably counsel you through how to do
this if you need guidance and that way
but you know I think that should happen
before you actually get to the feedback
stage
it's just my two cents I think it's
really important to kind of tease out
exactly what that person is looking for
to because they can say oh can you tell
me you know what I need to do better but
I think it's important to look at okay
when is this conversation happening is
it happening when you're doing your
performance review with them this year
and so really the translation is what
can I do so that I can get an excellent
you know are an outstanding on my
performance review or is it you know
what can I do kind of somebody referred
to earlier today as in that whole
personality camp you know what kind of
softer skills I guess is the phrase i'm
looking for to improve or what kind of
technical skills do i need to improve in
my job so i think it's really important
to not just take that question at face
value but to tease out what that
individual is really looking for when
they ask for feedback i think there are
two pieces to it first of all we come
back again to this whole notion of trust
and that trust needs to be inherent in
that relationship in order for you to
have that dialogue in terms of whatever
is agreed upon you know sort of putting
on my reference librarian had I mean
you've got to have a reference interview
about it you need to really get a sense
of what it is that the person is looking
for and I think that the person who's in
the mentoring role also needs to think
about whether or not they're the
appropriate person to provide the advice
that the the person wants because really
what you may not necessarily need to do
is say you know Courtney you talk with
your hands too much and you really
should work on that you know maybe that
person isn't the right you know maybe
Damon because he's sitting right fund me
maybe he's not the right person that
gave me that advice he may say you know
I'm really I'm glad you asked me I'm
going to be happy to work with you but I
know from experience that having more
than one mentor is really important and
so you know if with your permission I
you know I'd like to introduce you you
know in person via email google hangout
whatever to star so that you know
because star has other strengths that I
don't have and they're things that she
might be able to work with you on that
you you know
will be more appropriate than that
she'll have a way of framing her way of
talking about you know saying you know
we have a lot in common you know we both
like to talk with our hands like to do
this you know one of the things that
someone advise me and I it was fine
because I don't really know them very
well so I'm so I'm not this is really
hypothetical I don't know maybe maybe
it's not hypothetical um but it but you
know weird she might have a way of
framing and talking to me about it that
would make me say oh yeah in certain
situations you know it may make sense
for me not to talk with my an so much
but if but Damon said it to me I might
be like wow you know I can't I can't
believe I can't believe you threw me
under the bus that way you know well I
can't you know while he's really looking
at me very critically so I think that
that those building relationships the
recognition that you know getting a
mentor doesn't mean having that one
person it means having multiple people
it means recognizing the power that you
have when you're in that role and how
you can help that person and helping
that person might be also finding
someone else to have certain types of
conversation to bring certain strengths
to mentoring and that includes peer
mentors absolutely that's another thing
that when I first started I was very
lucky to be set up with peer mentors so
it wasn't an above or below situation
but it was somebody who had been around
the organization longer and could start
to give me some insight into the way
that things worked or you know how to
get feedback and so that was equally
helpful you're like i just want to jump
in and say talk about what about with my
distinction between coaching and
mentoring just for a second because a
lot of times when we talk about
mentoring coaching we talk about them
interchangeably is this mic on yeah okay
to me and to us where i work mentoring
is isn't it as a relationship where
somebody can get gives advice to
somebody else here's my issue what do
you think well here's what I would do
far were in that position that's a min
relationship and that's perfectly valid
in and good the coaching relationship is
bit different so if you're meeting with
a peer coach my job as your peer coach
isn't to give you advice my job as a
coach is to say well boy have you ever
had that experience before what did you
do that worked huh what didn't work hmm
what can you do maybe differently this
time we're better this isoh so as a
coach I ask a lot of questions and I let
the person sort through what works for
them and what doesn't work for them as a
mentor I give advice I direct people I
encourage them I am much it's a it's a
it's a it is a different relationship
for me so when I talk about and i just
realized as you were you were talking I
didn't ever really define that when I
talked about the peer coaching programs
that we run it really is a different
animal than mentoring so we are
launching an official mentoring program
we've always had informal mentoring but
a more formal mentoring program that
will sit side by side by the coaching
program they do different things I think
we have time for one more and we have
one more person at the microphone so I'm
sorry as far as is my Maya third time
and I'm usually not this vocal but
there's just so much meat here that's
our disc of material here that is just
amazing and i love the buzz that I
always get when i come to columbia i
think that it's very important for us as
we're summing up to remember that this
question is being asked in a mill year
that is much larger than simply the
library world or the leadership world
and as someone who does a lot of
mentoring and some coaching i read
extensively about work rate readiness
and also about the changing scenery and
an education both higher education and
what comes before that including core
curriculum and so forth and i think that
one thing that all around is being
talked about is the lack of work
readiness of gray
graduates from high schools from
colleges from grad schools and what can
be done to bridge this gap so I think
it's excellent that we as librarians who
are sitting in this seat of power
somewhat to understand that we have a
tremendous amount of influence as was as
Courtney brought out particularly as it
comes to trying to get and and i think
also i'm sorry the woman in the middle
who's the yes kitty is it yes who comes
to who is doing a hybrid this is what we
have to do more we've talked about
embedded librarianship some previous
symposiums and places but i think what
has to be what conclusions must be is
that we have to create a future Peter
trucker talks about this and other
forward-thinking people that the passive
is good in some cases but I think for
leadership is just simply expressing
ourselves and trying things out with
people whom you can identify with but to
let this situation go is only going to
exasperate an already bad situation and
I think the economic situation certainly
has contributed to it the cost of higher
education the values of a diploma
against positions of employment but all
of this is something that has been gone
through before I think life is cyclical
and I think that if people take to heart
the good things that have been said here
I think the people can go forward the
worst thing is to leave a symposium
where you're filled with inspiration and
then not do anything so I'm hoping that
this conversation will be continued and
perhaps they'll be a wiki or some sort
of blog where people can contribute
mentioned building a bibliography maybe
when people go home they'll think of
further sources and share those things
because I really enjoyed this symposium
over some of the others that I haven't
have attended has really been
spectacular thank you
well thank you i think i think you've
done my wrap-up I don't have to do the
wrap up yes I do so first again join me
in thanking all of our speakers for
today and can I just ask that the
planning committee and volunteers and
our wonderful MC stand up for thank you
and we of course thank our sponsors but
we especially thank you for taking the
time to come here and spend a day with
us some of you traveled a few blocks
some a few miles some many miles so
thank you this event has been successful
because of you and to assess the success
of the event you know it's coming right
I've been asked to say in a few days you
will receive an email providing you with
a link to a survey and when you receive
the email please take yet another few
more minutes you've already invested a
lot of time so a few more minutes as
nothing to respond to this survey
because your feedback will provide us
with essential information about future
symposium planning so thank you again
for attending and for participating in
the survey and for the wonderful
thoughtful conversation